marco rodríguez maestro de profesión no
dudó en dar su voto a pedro casi o con
la esperanza de que las condiciones
sociales de los peruanos cambiaran un
año después está desilusionado porque la
economía educación y salud sus mayores
promesas de campaña no han mejorado
literalmente decepcionado porque
todo lo que él dijo no los pacientes su
propia familia están siendo tal vez
beneficiados y están beneficiándose de
lo que son las inversiones están metidos
en cosas de corrupción como por su parte
ciro silva admite que no ha habido
mejorías con castigo sin embargo lo
apoya y responsabiliza a los partidos de
derecha por dificultar la labor del
presidente peruano potenciar escándalos
para afectar su imagen y hacerlo dimitir
en el congreso de la república le ha
marcado el paso la obstrucción para que
pueda seguir desarrollando los proyectos
o sea no ha podido cumplir lo que ha
ofrecido al pueblo peruano y esto es lo
que huele por ahora pedro castillo se
enfrenta a una presunta acusación de
dirigir una organización criminal uno de
varios procesos que la fiscalía le ha
abierto entre tanto revuelo político los
indicadores económicos y sociales no
mejoran según los analistas la inflación
bordea el 9% mientras la pobreza llega
al 30 por ciento unas cifras mayores de
cuando asumió el poder no tiene mucha
capacidad de maniobra del presidente que
va a ser simplemente va
de seguir defendiéndose y esperemos que
no ocurra pero que en su desesperación
pueda buscar un expediente totalitario o
un camino duro cómo disolver el congreso
si era silva junto a otros ciudadanos se
organiza para encontrar nuevas
alternativas los peruanos quieren un
cambio en la clase política y en sus
autoridades pero cumple 201 años de
independencia sin embargo el país vive
la misma polarización y los mismos
problemas que tenía cuando se inició
como república